digamos que tengo un ángulo que voy a
llamar a bs y que luce más o menos así
voy a tener el vértice en el punto b
el lado b va a estar más o menos así
aquí está el punto y el punto bc perdón
el lado b se va a estar más o menos
este es mi punto b perdón mi punto c del
ángulo a b c y digamos también que tengo
otro ángulo que voy a llamar este ángulo
lo voy a llamar de b a de b
y el ángulo que va a lucir así este va a
tener el vértice también en b y el lado
b d va a estar así dv aquí va a estar d
y digamos que la medida del ángulo de
beat va a ser igual a 40 grados y
también sabemos que la medida del ángulo
abc es igual a 50 grados
hay varias cosas interesantes una de
ellas es que ambos ángulos comparten un
uno de sus lados en particular es este
lado b
cuando tenemos dos ángulos que comparten
el mismo lado se les llama ángulos
adyacentes así que estos son
ángulos
los
adyacentes
ya que esta palabra significa que están
juntos otra cosa interesante que pueden
haber notado es que sabemos que el
ángulo de bea es igual a 40 grados y que
el ángulo abc es igual a 50 grados
probablemente ustedes ya se han dado
cuenta de que si medimos el ángulo el
ángulo de bs
bc
la medida de este ángulo va a ser igual
a la suma de estos dos ángulos es decir
la suma de 50 grados más 40 grados que
será igual a 90 grados si colocamos un
transportador aquí un transportador más
o menos
así el primer ángulo este sería de 50
grados este le agregaremos este otro
ángulo que es el de vea que es de 40
grados y nos quedaría este ángulo de bbc
de 90 grados un ángulo recto
así que ya sabemos que este es un ángulo
especial y se llama ángulo recto
recto
y tenemos una palabra especial para los
ángulos cuya suma de 90 grados y es
complementarios así que también podemos
decir que el ángulo de b
y el ángulo a b c son son
complementarios complementarios
se complementan y eso es debido a que su
suma de 90 grados
la medida del ángulo de b
de a
más la medida del ángulo a veces es
igual a 90 grados otra terminología
asociada a los ángulos rectos es que los
lados de un ángulo recto o terminador es
o rayos que lo forman son
perpendiculares entre sí debido a que
sabemos que el ángulo de vc es igual a
90 grados esto también nos indica que el
lado debe el lado de b
perpendicular
perpendicular perpendicular
al lado que se forma por b y c
la palabra perpendicular puedo escribir
que el segmento o el lado de b
es perpendicular
al lado de ser
este símbolo nos indica que son dos
líneas perpendiculares
todos estos enunciados son verdaderos y
salen del hecho de que el ángulo formado
por los datos debe y veces de 90 grados
tenemos otro término para ángulos que
sumados son iguales a otras cosas
digamos que aquí tengo este ángulo
voy a dibujar en azul voy a dibujar este
ángulo así
va a tener su vértice y este punto de
aquí va a ser x
y este punto de aquí base z y este
ángulo x y y ceta va a ser igual a 60
grados
y voy a tener otro ángulo que va a lucir
así
tener este lado
aquí y
este terminados
acá
y este va a tener los puntos su vértice
bases n
este lado o este punto va a ser m y acá
va a estar el punto y entonces este va a
ser mi ángulo m n
y este ángulo m n va a medir va a ser
igual a 120 grados de aquí acá esto va a
ser igual a 120 grados si sumamos la
medida que la voy a escribir la medida
de el ángulo x y z más la medida de mi
ángulo m n o este ángulo mide 60 grados
este otro medio 120 que en de hecho no
lo escribí aquí viene el 120 esto es 10
120 grados 120 más 60 va a ser igual a
180 grados
esencialmente recordemos medio círculo
con estos dos ángulos cuando tenemos
ángulos cuyas sumadas 180 grados los
llamamos suplementarios
a veces esto no es tan sencillo de
recordar los que tienen 90 grados se
complementan los que suman 180 grados
son suplementarios este es un ángulo
ángulo
el comentario suple
dios
escribo bien lado y si además vemos que
estos ángulos suplementarios tienen un
lado en común como es este segmento
x o n van a ser ángulos suplementarios
adyacentes
ya sientes
escribirnos bien la cee y debido a que
son adyacentes y suplementarios el
ángulo formado por los lados
estos dos lados momento24 com
estos ángulos el ángulo que voy a llamar
aquí el ángulo
m n z lo que forma por estos segmentos m
n z va a ser un ángulo llano
este es un
ángulo
ya no
porque es igual a 180 grados creo que
con eso tenemos todas las herramientas
necesarias para comenzar a hacer algunas
demostraciones interesantes como repaso
aquí hablamos de ángulos adyacentes
aquellos que suman 90 grados se les
llama complementarios y si estos son
adyacentes
entonces los lados externos eran
perpendiculares los lados de un ángulo
recto se consideran perpendiculares
entre sí y si tenemos dos ángulos que
suman 180 grados se llamarán
suplementarios y si resultan ser
adyacentes formarán un ángulo llano otra
forma de verlo es que si tenemos un
ángulo llano y dentro hay otro ángulo el
ángulo restante será suplementario al
primero